we're here with karla lolly music and we
are in the midst of making a sunday ragu
from her latest cookbook that sounds so
good
and we've got some garlic and onions
cooking in the pot yup carla you're in
the driver's seat i am your passenger
next let's do this okay so now that
these are like browned and starting to
caramelize and get softened they're
perfect they're not too burnt no
becoming translucent
i really feel with ragu because it's
such a long cooking process like all of
the flavors are going to come out you
just have to give them time so grab one
of your cans of tomatoes the tomatoes
have actually already been pureed
because they don't want like big chunks
no just from your can that's got a
little i only have water in there that's
fine that's what we want you just pour a
little bit of water in here just to i'm
not expecting that just to deglaze and
like pull up all of those brown bits
deglaze glazing
because all of those bits are our flavor
so you could use wine you could use
water you could use a little splash of
stock it's as long as it loosens it up
it's all good waters wine stock yeah all
are on it's all good it's all just
dissolving
a little bit if you could pick any one
what's your flavor in the book i think
it calls for red wine but that's only if
you have a bottle open i'm not going to
tell anybody open a bottle of wine for a
quarter cup you know what i mean to use
a splash of water it does the same thing
it's dissolving and then after that just
go ahead
carefully i wore red in case i splash
i did not
i almost wore white but i thought better
of it
yeah
so this goes in
gorgeous
um we have a little oregano a couple of
bay leaves right there i love a bay leaf
drop those guys in and again these are
personal choices you could use basil you
could use rosemary
i do think oregano immediately like a
cumin transports a dish in seconds you
cannot mess with cumin or oregano they
just go they go right to the heart and
oregano is one of those that like even
as a dried herb it's one of the few
dried herbs that has just wonderful
flavor punch yeah meats are going back
in the sauce meats in the sauce so we've
got our pork shoulder beautiful brown
and we've got our beautiful brajol
which is really pronounced bastiole but
the italian americans will say
i i i recognize it from that and i don't
recognize the other but i
i'm hoping oh
sorry there goes that dry cleaning
switch
and then these sausages i actually don't
brown which i was very skeptical even
myself
this recipe it just felt really weird
not to brown them before putting them in
but they become amazing so you just
don't need to you don't need to wrap
around the sausage
because that's going to cook for so long
and it just becomes i said in the book
until the the end point is soft enough
to feed to a toothless baby because
that's what i had that was my guess that
night so this is going to go for like
two and a half three hours you can put
up your pergola you can like do whatever
you want i will take a nap you could
dress your table siesta siesta get the
men to make the homemade wine whatever
you need to do you've got fresh bread
like lucy that's right we're gonna crush
grapes and then two and a half three
hours later we have the magic you're
gonna have ready one two three beautiful
magic
[Applause]
oh it's like we made a baby carla
and you can just see we call this the
the cat line from cat and hat where he
goes in the bathtub and it leaves a line
that's the cat line you can see how much
the sauce has reduced when you look
around the edge right
and how much it's come down the color
the color is amazing i love this sauce
so what i like to do now is take a bit
of the sauce we have our cooked um pasta
you can use any shape i just think a
short you have your little pot here
this guy just sauce that guy up oh i got
it
a little bit of sauce and
if you have your i heard you talking
about pasta water earlier ah
very and it's key
so just a splash of that starchy water
which is also salty
and i also learned don't ever put oil in
the water ever never ever and the reason
you don't do that is because it
basically makes the noodles water
resistant because they're coated in oil
so then when you add them to the sauce
the sauce just slides off we don't want
that we want the sauce to soak in that's
why i love like a fusilli type of pasta
that sauce really sticks
and also with this rigatoni that's all
that sauce is going to get inside and
you call this a meze mesmerigato which
means half so it's a shorty
yeah so i call it bite size and quicker
i know i'm
so i like to bring this sort of sauce
the pasta up and then you can come to
the table you've got all your meats
beautifully prepared and everybody can
kind of take what they like and then add
it to add it to your plate
[Music]